it was just since you're the wonderful
news that she is cancer-free and one
hundred percent healthy and she's busier
than ever with a new movie coming out
and a new CD and I talked to Rita about
how music helped her heal how his music
helped you in recovery it's music is the
thing that actually can change your mood
no matter what you're doing whether it's
listening to music or being able to
write these songs it's been an amazing
outlet not only when you're feeling sad
but when you're feeling happy to Rita
wrote songs about her entire life for
her new self-titled album including her
27 year marriage to Tom Hanks he makes a
cameo in her music video and he'll
travel with Rita on her 21 cities spring
tour they'll travel by bus and it's
gonna be packed so when you have your
own tour bus and then a band will have a
note we're all on there to guess there
is that how many people in the band
there's eight total on the bus why it
sleeps 12 so you can call i'm telling
you you can come alright i'm beyond my
past rita was shooting the cover for cv
Lux magazine before our interview she's
super busy also producing and acting in
my big fat greek wedding too written by
and starring her good friend nia
vardalos since the first movie came out
what surprises me is how everyone sees
their family in this family I would have
people coming up to me and saying this
is our story ian is a vegetarian he
doesn't eat meat what do you mean you
don't eat no meat that's okay I me clap
John Corbett instincts Joey Fatone and
the whole cast returned for the sequel
fast forwarding now years later now
Paris who is too
ians daughter is grown up when I'm
approaching a screenplay I try to pull
for my real life my family showed up to
be back round after here you go I know
now what it's like to be a mom and I
could write about all the angst of
wanting to keep my daughter close even
though I'm taking a step back I will
always be right here